[Music]
do what you love and love what you do
tap dance to work so no single day
you know it's boring days we don't have
the monday blooms or the friday corners
right
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
20 minute leaders is a proud supporter
of make-a-wish israel and tech to peace
and is in proud collaboration with
secret core adventures j ventures
riverside fm
fusion vc
birthright excel j impact leap google
for startups and hippo and in media
partnership with ctec
welcome to 20 minute leaders today we're
talking to brijesh damodaran the
co-founder and chief investment officer
of aksano an early stage venture capital
firm that invests in growth stage
businesses across industries a strategic
thinker and a purpose-driven individual
bridgesh completed chartered accountancy
and graduation from the university of
mumbai
soon after acquiring his educational
intent bridges embarked on his
professional journey in the corporate
world working in the oil and gas space
telecom and mortgage guarantee space
serving in various roles in accounts
finance and compliance in fortune 500
company
he donned the entrepreneurial hat in
2009 in the wealth management space as a
solopreneur
bridgesh thank you so much for being
here on 20 minute leaders how are you
i'm doing good you know thank you
michael
how are you good good thank you very
much for being here talking about your
own journey and about you know your your
your your journey within the indian
ecosystem and how your career has
developed and transformed and today
dealing with some some interesting
companies um so it would just take me
back all the way you know to to the
beginning getting sort of the
equivalency of a cpa
what's been sort of your guiding
your guiding motivation or getting force
from
as early as you'd like to go
so very simple
do what you love and love what you do
tap dance to work so no single day
you know it's boring days you don't have
the monday blooms or the friday corners
right
so you can you can leave the way and
lead the way and you follow that and
that's what the whole thing is and what
helps is focus focus on what you do
and focus on your strengths
so and you know
does that mean you allow your weakness
to be there or not to be there so there
can be no rise or right answer to that
the most important part is being focused
so if you say like we are as a firm we
manage public moneys
through the wealth management arm called
well weather which means leading
indicators and we are also a vc firm
based out of india which is
regulated by sebi
uh and in that case when we also handle
you know the startup space big time and
it is growing big time out here india so
the only thing which helps is focus so
we try to
uh i'm not saying we try we bring in the
signals in the public markets into the
private market and earnings from both
and can move forward because we believe
the next
10 15 years
you know india as a country is
beautifully placed and i'm thankful for
having that genetic order in my favor at
this point of time
so thanks very much
as we speak
so how did you how did your own journey
develop to get to this to get to this
focus that you're talking about
so one thing you know numbers
data and narrative and all three was
always you know part of it
and that is where we want to you know
share that so if you can
like if you look talk about a product if
you got a great product but we cannot
communicate
then and the product may not you know go
good so let's talk about horse and the
jockey you know
good horse and a good jockey is like you
know it's like perfectly place whereas a
you know good house and a bad job keys
so from that way if you're seeing so the
early
decade or two you know
was in the corporate space you know
worked in sectors including oil and gas
telecom
uh yeah what more case guarantees and
all of this was growing in india as such
and had a firsthand exposure
to that so worked in fortune 500
companies both in india and all and
global
and then one fine they said you know
you can have more fun
being an entrepreneur so i had a
deadline date and year and
lobbying started my wealth management
journey and during that time the indian
ecosystem was slowly growing
in terms of
you have flip card which got acquired by
walmart somewhere in 2017 huge
uh and you talk about unicorns being the
world all over and that is getting a
substantial share of that of that space
so if you say
in 2015 india had 11 unicorns but in
2022 as of date we have more than 100.
wow
so i know so let's say when i say you
know so that this is crazy like how you
know like you're talking about it today
we're talking about yeah today over the
last two quarters are not the right time
to talk about the unicorns or or funding
but yes these these
stages will definitely be there but we
need to look beyond them for the father
and that's how we got into place so we
so what are sectors which come into play
so we talk about you know so as it as we
shared earlier server we have a simple
thesis you know invest in tech enabled
negligent consumer focus because india
is a land of huge land of consumers and
multiple you know segments and which has
either a subscription or a secular you
know income which can come in and that
is again
where we talk about so
be defended platforms or be the
analytics platform or beat genome
sequencing i know which is getting more
and more traction as we speak
yeah and then you know it takes stays
outside of the k20 which is huge and you
know yeah you know lightly place again
and over on the we are the only pc firm
in india which has
investments in geospatial space across
two different segments one is
other in mapping and the most which the
recent indian government policy over the
last 12 15 months i've given has given a
huge boost and you know tremendous
impetus for the growth in these sectors
so the kind of thing which can happen is
mind-boggling and synergies and
partnerships
both locally and locally
can help the world to make a better
place
how do you
how do you sort of filter or prioritize
on
you know there's so many different
startups
it's exp you know just like the number
of unicorns has been building in india
the though the number of startups has
been crazy how do you how do you even as
an investor in the indian ecosystem in
the early stage ecosystem even
figure out
you know how
how to even approach this sort of a big
funnel problem
now i should thank simon sinek for his
book why
so we start with why
you know why how does it make matt how
does it help and like why we should
invest and and why and most importantly
since we manage both public monies and
privately and private capital
we look at you know after the location
of our clients monies across sectors and
create wealth so which which is which is
huge
so
keeping things simple has helped us so
when we look into it
see whether it is a
the proposed or potential entity use
either is it a category creator
is it a market creator or is it a market
owner
or
if you say from a category creator can
move into a market creator market owner
so one very first investments which we
did you know was in the e-grocery space
and india's beautiful place because
uh eat grocery is big time you know
e-commerce and groceries you know it's
big time out here
and
when we actually invest for the first
time we looked at two things being a cpa
also helped me in the sense that you
know the
the in the potential the prospective
investment company required negative
working capital so when you say negative
working capital is losing two years so
first it had
if you want to order goods order a
service you have to either do a prepaid
ballot for that so that means unless you
put in money you don't get delivered
which is beautiful this is music two
years right
and that's where and then you had a
beautiful ux and ui
so so
when you want to check out
it was not that you have to go and check
out and so it had and and and ux wherein
you know you are wearing you not put in
the goods and that's it and that's a
check out and this empire 2016 which is
like you know today just like d regard
but that point of time it was not as
such there right so when you are able to
look into that you know and then it's
okay fine so now then you carry the
execution risk
that you cannot help right that you
simply cannot help that will happen
remind me how how early how early do you
operate in the in the investment side
so we don't operate uh at an addition
stage we typically would want to have
say you know some sort of a revenue to
kick in but having said that you know
we are not
held to that because today the ecosystem
is changing so this could have held to
some till about 20 20 21 but today a lot
of more things are there there is a lot
more investment appetite and also the
risk appetite among the uh among the
employees to haven't played so when i'm
going back to the world first earlier
thing so when you thought about you know
that so you had
all things in play it was a category
creator
slowly became a market creator and whole
period of time and became a market owner
and it was acquired by one of india's
largest entity
outright so
it played out
but yeah
did we say it would play out that way
obviously not but we knew you know that
you know unless there is an active the
execution disk which you which which as
an entrepreneur you have to take right
be it a bc or be
be an entrepreneur you have to take that
that call and we did that con and and
that has helped us to make better soak
our three pillars category theater
market creator market owner deep dive
into that again we have the three touch
points like within three touch points we
actually proceed to for the next
investing or we say no to the to the to
the prospective footprint of weapons
investing companies
what are you personally most most
excited by what what types of companies
so obviously you know everything you
said sounds
you know it sounds like a great
investment strategy what are you
personally really excited by
so let me put it this way you know if i
i may be something saying something
different but
the most of the first things when i we
look into it is that you know when i
enjoy you know
sharing my coffee or a drink with with
the perspective founder even three years
from now four years from now because we
are getting into a relationship right we
are not getting into it into one night
stand
that nice
so that's very important one part of it
but besides because see no one looks it
talks about this part but this is a very
integral part you know very important
part in the investment journey when vc
has
with a potential continent but then the
other thing things come and see fix into
place whether you know what is a growth
aspect what is the founder competence is
a founder approachable you know what is
a mode you know yeah and and if an early
stage or do we see you know if i apply
for you know connection of investments
or pipeline for growth you know
geographically place
all other things which you know which
typically comes in play does come into
that but the intensibles also does play
a role you know for that for that matter
the dd come into play today gardens we
talked about big time but we are always
been
uh
been fond of governance and many times
on our
our and companies say that you know
you're asking for too much but
let me say that nearly eight to nine
percent of our money is invested so we
have got deep screen in the game it is
not a typical
there's much beyond that so we are so
it's like you know our personal
commitment and our personal you know uh
let's say belief that you know and also
uh it's an insight in which which are
also sharing with a to our lp saying
that the gps are not only for 220 but
gpus are most in the game you know than
any of you so that's where
we come from so both tangible and
intangibles you know it comes and comes
into play
and so once you've actually made this
investment and you mentioned a few times
sort of the relationship that you're
building with
the organization that
that you're you're working with how are
you
you know what what is sort of your
relationship with the founders as you
see it as time goes by what are you
prioritizing how how does this
relationship
sort of come to be
and and and what what are you trying how
are you trying to position yourself sort
of in what role for the founders
see
we have to look at two aspects one
aspect as a we've seen uh
i need to have an myc error for my
my my my nps point number one that is
driven by how
you know the the the founders drive
their companies you know we are open to
founders and don't give a free hand at
the same point of time you know looking
at the data and numbers so we have this
you know monthly mis systems in place
quarterly calls we talked about
connecting with you know
performance coaches as inventor required
because we believe you know the best you
know we are we are we are not someone
who wants to sit and direct and guide
like in terms of how to run the business
we are here to ensure that we don't miss
the marks you know we
we connect with you with our ecosystem
we connect you to experts uh we believe
today as a founder many times if not so
say things as openly as you want to be
that's why we say please share yourself
a friend very affluently uh don't
consider us as as someone who's going to
monitor you and has been sick on top of
you but consider us as part of your as a
partner in your journey head you know
walk hand in hand and then you know it's
like today we have two types of funds
with us you know one fund which we
invest currently and want to hand exit
by fourth or fifth year the other fund
which would you know can have the growth
capital and take you forward so an
investor's journey and the investment
journey both are different we want with
part of the entire investment generated
through two through two funds which we
which we have you know so that way
uh our you know the portfolio companies
are also aware that no if you have good
and the more capital can come into play
and we can also bring in you know other
key stakeholders in the goodwood story
and other things so from that
perspective you definitely do that
and so looking forward tell me a little
bit about sort of your own vision you're
mentioning that you're talking a lot
about journey and fulfillment
and tell me about how you how you see
your own journey progress and and what
what are you hoping for
so the only thing no like say you know
like
we are there along with our lp so you
know we want the lps to make money and
grow we want to bring different
geographies uh in the sense that our lps
needs to come from different geographies
and make money you know where money so
be it india or between the geographies
we want to do that
i'll not give a hardcore number the only
thing which i would say is that
i should or as a company you know as a
vc firm um the gps the lps my team they
should tap dance to work uh the investor
communication which we share you know
today on a quarterly basis to the tower
with our lps are like no i like platinum
that's all things which i've seen from
others we say not the communication
which we share in a nine blocker sheet
is much more informative uh we are open
for his suggestions and if whatever it
should enjoy you know when we talk about
all the journals about bella weather you
know
the healthies and all the investors
should say yes you know i got my cash
flows the returns would come in you know
absolutely but no what was my moi see
what does my i had that will flow but at
the same point of time like when i put
in the geospatials when we invest in
geospatial space in 2017 it was very
early and
but today
it's dying thing so without we have been
being you know
looking forward
it will help us you know from that
perspective so we're trying to get those
right we try to you know enjoy the
journey have fun alongside uh it may not
be even steep repair the same straight
yeah no but you may have with ups and
downs and that's what it is like but end
of the day every one of our emphasis
should feel that should not feel should
make money no they should be happy with
the money you know that they make that's
right
and and what are sort of the types of
founders that you most enjoy working
with
and when you're looking at sort of the
people that you're trying to partner
what are the qualities of traits that
you're most excited by or that you most
resonate with
see the most important part is that you
know they should tap pants to be sure to
enjoy they should eat leave pretty sleep
you know so you talk about stephanie's
japanese diablo in the car right and
also when alexander was really know when
to conquer the world he always burnt his
ships and told the soldiers that if you
want to go back make a new ship so you
know maybe that is taking it too far but
having said that you know you're having
it you know yeah having plan a plan b
plants is great but you know the thing
doesn't have the vision we should feel
it and favorite does happen and we are
open to that uh you should enjoy uh you
should share very openly uh
you should have you know see it's ethics
integrity is all by default should be
there it is or something you know unless
another thing is that you should enjoy
the drink and the coffee you know and
other part you know you you can be you
can have a mission ship but you know if
it can't be you know you may not be it
may not be a friend per se but if
anything is happening both good or bad
you know the founders should feel you
know let me first connect with the vc
and take you know dive into place and
see how best we can go with joining
hands are good to that they should feel
that they should know that you know
because we follow that to data and if
they find anything amiss doing that they
should feel confident they should feel
strong to talk discuss or we may
disagree to that but at the same point
of time if if you are open to share and
you have the vision you know in clear
set terms so if you ask us we are like a
delay of cake you know and also
things so help us understand so the
thing is that if you can help understand
the clue of care then i think that's
done the same thing we follow like like
i am not a tech guy but for me the tech
is that how much you see the ux or the
eins how what is the manageability of it
you know what is the back end of it or
the security of it all the way in place
so let tell me the basics part so you
get the basics part then you move the
step forward so that's the whole play so
why why why becomes huge and the answer
to the wise comes in play then the what
when how come into play so that's then
hence input so three simple stuff having
a lot of basic stuffs in place is what
we talked with we have to talk talk
about
incredible bridges thank you so much for
it for taying the time to be here sounds
like uh beyond the fact that it's an
interesting journey for you it sounds
like you're very intentional about it
and then you're really looking to have
fun along the way and to really enjoy
them because and be fulfilled with it
and it sounds like you
you you very much are treating it as
sort of an entrepreneurial experience
like any other and not just wealth
management not just investing but really
from a very intentional point of view
and so i really appreciate that and i
appreciate your time and your effort and
your energy so thank you very very much
for being here sharing your story and i
and i look forward to sharing this with
the world thank you michael cheers to
you
[Music]